Opposers, the NRA
is silent no more.
Today NRA chief Wayne LaPierre
or in English Wayne 'The' Pierre
responded to the shooting
in Parkland.
As usual, the opportunists
wasted not one second
to exploit tragedy
for political gain.
They hide behind labels
like democrat to make their
socialist agenda
more palatable, palatable,
palatable, palatable.
Evil walks
among us and God help us
if we don't harden our schools
and protect our kids.
That's right, NRA.
Evil walks
among us. The socialist pinkos
want to have a conversation
about gun control
are leaving our kids exposed.
Pure evil.
But don't panic opposers.
Luckily we have one
narrow bit of hope.
Control of the presidency
and the House and the Senate
and the judiciary
and two thirds of governorships
and state legislatures
and 98 percent of all
Cracker Barrel franchises.
Can you imagine if we didn't?
Then they come for our handguns,
our AR-15s, our Remington R-25s,
our glock-22s, our BB guns,
our BB8s. Before you know it,
Hillary is president
and your Cracker Barrel
is a Planned Parenthood
giving out free abortion
with every pecan pancake!
Are you scared? Good.
Maybe you should go
and buy a gun.